welcome to technical  you can trust your car to the system  with the star check the garden  technical editing here  shark still looks fake yeah yeah yes  thank you yes you want to know what  happens to your gift they all come to me  in your car you see what I'm saying in  your garbage I could hurt myself with  all the bad Christmas neckties I found  it and up the avarice never ends I won't  talk up I want diamonds I want a booty  so i can write it twice get bored and  tell it to make glue right hi hi hi hi  got a little carried away uh explaining  the inner workings of the institution to  gym mm-hmm hmm i don't really come from  out of space Oh LJ Washington he doesn't  really come from outer space don't mock  me my friend good i'm a chair it's a  condition of mental divergence i find  myself on the planet olga part of an  intellectual relieved